keine zeit für weihnachten
ihnen kann geholfen werden
die völlig neue aktions box weihnachten
zügen mit unserer jenny aus dem
geschulten serviceteam erleben sie ein
typisches weihnachtsfest in nur 30
sekunden und das tolle daran
sie haben so noch mehr zeit für ihren
stressigen und dämlichen job bereit
ja na dann los jenny stufe 1
weihnachtsstimmung
[Musik]
stufe 2 musik
stufe drei geschenke auspacken stufe 4
festtagsmenü unsere neu entwickelte
weihnachten to go injektion
sie besteht aus purem fette und
entspricht der menge die sie
normalerweise in der ganzen
weihnachtszeit mit plätzchen und
gänsebraten zu sich nehmen
so sparen sie zeit und lästiges futtern
und können gezielt gewicht an den
unterschiedlichsten körperstellen
zulegen oberbauch oder am allerwertesten
ihre fantasie sind keine grenzen gesetzt
suchen sie sich ihre lieblingsstellen
selbst aus und wenn sie weihnachten züge
jetzt bestellen
gibts gratis noch einen handfesten
ehestreit mit dazu und was ist mit
meiner branche
die essenz von weihnachten in nur 30
sekunden mit weihnachten to go
[Applaus]